in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Philip
and Dominique are with us how are you
Wow how are you doing well
cool cool so what city do you live in
Madame Elena alright welcome to
Nashville we're glad you're here and
here to do your debt free scream yeah I
love it and so how much have you paid
off 90 mm all right very cool and how
long did that take 24 months good for
you Wow and your range of income during
that time uh it started around 1:40 and
upwards of 150 Wow what do you guys do
for a living I'm a technical support
engineer and I'm a retail consultant
good for you guys very well done what
kind of debt was the 90 mm oh your mind
$92,000 yeah I mean going through it it
was uh we didn't think about it much we
just we were doing it and it's making
traction finally but it was all student
loan debt oh really
Sallie Mae so who was who was the
well-educated one that would be
Dominique raising her hand for those of
you looking they private school for art
so ah there we go
okay ninety-two thousand dollars worth
yes all right that always helps you as a
retail consultant actually it does if
you think about shelf placement and
design and all that kind of thing so
there you go you never know well
congratulations you guys think very well
done so how long have you been married
nine years Wow so what happened twenty
four months ago that caused you guys to
get on fire and throw Sallie Mae in the
street well it actually started a little
bit before that we took FPU at our
church in spring of 2012 and we kind of
didn't do very much with it we did the
budget and we still did what we wanted
to do we went out to eat we put vacation
on there and we just made no traction
during that time
whatever was left over we put that
towards my student loans and we made no
progress okay um we had her son and you
would have thought that that woke us up
but it didn't um a few months after I
returned back from maternity leave I
walked into work
work and three people in my department
were let go in their cubes oh yeah and
that was welcomed yeah and that's where
I learned that stability as you say or
security is an illusion yeah and I think
we both kind of looked at each other and
felt like it's time if anything were to
happen I had been laid off once before
and that if anything were to happen at
least you know if we got our finances in
order it wouldn't be a crisis it would
just be you know something that was
inconvenient cool cool well that's Wow
good for you guys so um how do you get
through Financial Peace University and
not get fired up I think the amount was
just so large
oh wow it was really time yeah the first
time that we actually added it all up
together okay and I think we just was
overwhelming yes it was extremely
overwhelming
you eat thought if you dialed your
lifestyle back and still take forever
yes I liked it but it didn't it took 24
months yeah and over time we started to
hear more more stories of people paying
off large amounts of debt and a short
amount of time and that's when we really
felt like okay we can do this okay so
you're one of those stories for somebody
else today yeah way to go very cool
very neat well congratulations what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is discipline and doing the
budget mm-hmm I would say it's also
thankful having a thankful heart and
spirit
um I think when you keep your eyes
focused on all that God has blessed you
with you don't really have time to be
worried about you know what you may be
missing out on or what you don't have
for a whole 24 months I mean it's not
like yeah yeah you know yeah cuz now you
make 150 you got no debt congratulations
how does that feel it feels really good
was it worth the sacrifice yes it
definitely was yeah so what would you
tell the you that came out of financial
peace and didn't get fired up what would
you tell the you to rip the band-aid off
and just do it because we could have
been so much further ahead if we just
would have went ahead and did it know
that it you know actually sit down do
the math if you do rip the band-aid off
you could do it in 24 months but you got
to really rip it off yeah
you guys have been on beans and rice
yeah you've got no life and I'm what I
wanted to tell you was the hardest thing
about this for us was not eating out
we're total foodies and we love to
experience new restaurants try new
things experience other cultures through
food but um so with that we we wallowed
in it for probably about six months and
then a year and a half ago we decided to
start a food blog and that was our way
to continue to learn about food and try
different things cook things we wouldn't
normally cook out at home and it's also
we've been able to share it with others
oh very cool
well and you're debt-free and you're in
Nashville which is heaven for food yeah
yeah we got some serious food action
going around here right now so well
congratulations you two very well done
and your son is with you yes and how old
is he
here 3 3 years old and what is his name
Isaac okay so has Isaac been practicing
his debt-free screen a little bit maybe
a little bit trying maybe a little bit
ok well 3 you know that's oh good
looking guy okay very cool all right
Philip and Dominique and Isaac Atlanta
Georgia we got a copy of Chris Hogan's
return spired book for you because
that's the next chapter become very
wealthy and outrageously generous in the
process thank you sure so Philip and
Dominique and Isaac Atlanta $92,000 paid
off in 24 months making 140 to 150 count
it down let's hear a debt free scream 2
1 thank you Jesus we're debt-free
I love that well done well done well
done
well that right there's how it happens
folks excellent job very well done hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show